yep hello and welcome to this video yeah
this is a new blitz game against dark
passenger wow I've got a totally rotten
score against this guy minus 55 wins 10
losses one draw ok so let's see what I
can do in this game seems like yeah we
get a bank oh yeah let's do it here
before that should be an interesting
banco form with the white pieces let's
see i will never actually played that
right i doubt that i doubt it that
wasn't a good move water i have
completely forgotten all that works from
the other side anyway we'll see you
should be towards not to move them and
particularly happy about that have to
play something yeah yeah I could take at
least so you have to have to spend to
move
okay at least he cannot cancel we can't
careful yeah okay what am I thinking
here that's weird my thought process is
not exactly great Ian ok let's see unite
to be five min well it's almost a threat
night before yeah I'm happy to post
videos again I've had a break of not
quite sure two or three days I had lots
of work on an icc video series and i
absolutely needed a little bit of time
to refresh and yeah get back in to get
back into some shape and now i'm happy
to play some games again let's see I
wonder you will go in five but this is
for possible see 5 and 9 26 now doesn't
doesn't look right doesn't look like
enough compensation
looking one was of prophylactic move
against Bishop g4 why he has night
before in all kinds of situations okay
this is not too bad i get to d6 okay
this is the thing i need to get rid of
this as possible I wonder if I still
still should play this but this night c
5 which is extremely annoying or just
pawn to c5 that's the most ambitious
let's do it
maybe he can prepare fire king king edge
raid or something but i was thinking
look see one and then 96 oh just I'm
developing okay let's put this here we
should be six then thing to work all
that well okay so there yeah maybe just
this in 96 the bishop would have gotten
a good position only 60 I think taking
this one so bad how to do this here how
do I get maybe he ran in 94 and then
taking or something like that now i'm
also looking at a five pretty much
threatening to take the abbess's the way
to stop it and beyond to be five not
sure if that it will not be hard helps
to be honest really not sure but then i
would at least threaten this 95 stuff
again to get it back yeah maybe maybe
maybe I'm okay here maybe I'm okay so we
just goes back home I can a lot take 85
now then it goes to c6 probably
and he's attacking the friggin pawn
there what is strange move and it's good
or what I cannot take them maybe
actually Candace look 236 just too slow
no I cannot play this I'm elucidating
that's not good not good at all I was
thinking would be successes of course
nonsense it's complete nonsense and I'll
get such an erotic game i okayed well I
can take be seven but then I look down
[Music]
yeah strange really looked like I
thought I should have some compensation
down I mean I miss played the opening
probably not doing it all that well but
I felt like the dead must have been ok I
mean all those active pieces that can
never be better for black I really don't
think my day seven so 96 is correct i
cannot take it I had a complete
hallucination I was just thinking rupee
six would do me some good but of course
that doesn't doesn't help at all just
very very bad so this Yap that fosters
the obvious move I cannot take because
of that and I saw that but I just
thought the other thing would be in
would be better Jim stop this gives
gives this is roughly equal if he cannot
take I mean his pieces are completely
passive so he should not be able to do
something with the pawn of course it's
not great yes I should not fight for
equality like that I mean normally I
also don't play before but I wanted to
want to test that just III is of course
good for white it's a very good model
benoni with the tempo up I mean it's not
like better for whites there but it is
very okay this kind of benoni is a metal
morning benoni with white and then now
his play he will play d65 at some point
so this is a very good good line for
what they felt abencoe attempt what can
be worth trying I probably should do it
do it differently around here I don't
think that this is so great because I'm
the extra temple that i have here with
the
with d3d three years already am already
wrong I guess I have to play Bishop b2
something like that that makes more
sense anyway okay I need to get back
into stripes with a couple of games and
this was not the one to do it thanks for
watching